c'est un happening c'est un happening
coiffure alors oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe bonjour bonjour alors oui alors
mettez mettez-vous là bien sûr direct
alors vous voulez faire passer un
message vous êtes des coiffeurs oui tout
à fait alors vous mais pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas alors c'est pour vous êtes
tenus parce que vous êtes coiffer
c'était plus même si on est on est tout
nu parce que on se met à nu avec un
enfermement le micro pardon oui vous
êtes vous êtes donc vanessa
oui c'est ça d'accord bon en tout cas
c'est comme si vous étiez à billets
parce qu'on voit rien donc ça va en fait
vous êtes coiffeuse c'est ça c'est ça
vous avez deux salariés en plus de vous
et aujourd'hui vous êtes en grande
détresse c'est ça c'est des amis
coiffeur à vous non non c'est cette
saison j'ai envie je région d'accord
tous solidaires donc de des coiffeurs
ces deux personnes qui sont dans
d'autres corps de métiers que vous avez
avec vous non non c'est des coiffures
c'est que les coiffeurs d'accord qui
travaille pas avec vous mais vous êtes
tous coiffeur c'est bien ce que je
disais d'accord
reda alors vous allez me dire quels sont
vos com comment vous comporter en ce
moment est ce qu'il ya sur vos petites
pancartes
voilà vous mettez je préfère me mettre
nue avant que le gouvernement le fasse
un commerce non essentiels mais
essentiel pour nous faire vivre
indépendant est pas dans la merde
hashtag coiffeur à poil temps est dans
la merde exactement merci coiffeur c'est
vrai que les coiffeurs
on attendait tous et c'est fou - parce
qu'on attendait tous de savoir quand le
ministre a parlé
si les coiffeurs allait rester ouverts
ou pas c'était la question que tout le
monde se pose et j'ai vu un chantage
passer encore il ya quelques semaines ou
pour la majorité les français
le coiffeur était un commerce primordial
essentiel primordial alors moi j'ai
décidé de faire cours justement pour
peut avoir de problème mais pour des
gens qui ont des belle chevelure comme
geoffroy par exemple voilà c'est vrai
que pour lui c'est plus compliqué non
mais c'est vrai que les coiffeurs au
delà au delà bien sûr du coiffeur de
deux de se faire coiffer est ce que
disait karine tout à l'heure le coiffeur
c'est aussi on va discuter que coiffeur
on lui raconte sa vie on est content de
lier la lier aux mines de rien quand on
va chez le coiffeur on se dit on va y
passer toute la journée le dr son chevet
non mais c'est ça
s'il sent bien quoi on retrouve un
milieu social
on n'a plus forcément alors moi pour me
juger chez le toiletteur mais c'est vrai
que voilà vous aujourd'hui vous êtes
dans une situation très compliquée vous
avez deux salariés en plus de vous neuf
mille à dix mille euros de chiffre
d'affaires par mois ça j'avais fait ce
que j'ai pu commencer ce que vous aviez
avant la qu'ovide 9000 et 10000 euros de
chiffre d'affaires par mois jusqu'à six
clients en même temps dans le salon donc
ça marchait plutôt très bien et depuis
la commune pouvait tenir encore novembre
décembre sur votre trésorerie
vous avez donc oil angoisses du dépôt de
bilan en janvier 2021 ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure madame la ministre
c'est pouvoir anticiper aussi pour
pouvoir sauver voilà sa boîte là c'est
vrai qu'elle pouvait pas tellement
anticipé que les coiffeurs allait fermer
surtout dans une période où la
normalement je pense que le mois de
novembre et décembre
je pense que c'est vos plus gros mois
cartaut way novembre décembre c'est ça
reste ouais l'un des plus gros mois et
là c'est une catastrophe économique ça
c'est une catastrophe pour vous après
c'est vrai qu'on a moi je parle du
dernier à déconfinement j'avais fait
donc un prêt un de prêts de l'état
d'accord justement pour pour de la
trésorerie là on se retrouve à peut-être
faire une demande ou pas pouvoir
rembourser ce qui a été emprunté donc
moi les questions elles sont voilà on
devait être exonéré de charges ça va pas
été respectées on devait être voilà il
ya encore beaucoup de questions qui se
pose est donc donc voilà je suis là pour
avoir des réponses alors sur les
coiffeurs on va écouter aussi le
témoignage de carreaux caroline un micro
merci caroline aussi donc vous aviez
tout allait bien pour l'ouverture de
votre salon il ya onze ans les charges
restent est supportable est là depuis la
qu'ovide moins 20000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires sur l'année 2020 en comptant
deux mois de novembre et aujourd'hui
vous avez très peur vous aussi de deux
fermes et bien oui je dois dire que
effectivement le premier confinement a
déjà été très compliqué et pour moi il
n'était pas concevable qu'on ait un
deuxième confinement malgré qu
effectivement on est bien d'accord que
on a conscience
bien sûr de l'épidémie mais quand on a
pris finalement tout le protocole on a
dans les salons c'est vraiment strict on
a une hygiène qui irréprochable ça donc
vous comprenez pas pourquoi on vous a
fermé non surtout qu'on a le masque du
début à la fin de la prestation qu'on
reçoit un client par un client moi dans
mon cas je travaille toute seule je
reçois un client toutes les demi-heures
l'existence à sion sont respectées le
masque le port du masque et respecter
enfin c'était vrai on était vraiment
dans l'incompréhension totale par
rapport à d'autres commerces
alors il ya aussi que l'on peut le
passer le micro
arnaud arnaud vous aussi employé à terre
de votre salon depuis 13 ans on avait
une employée et depuis la colline
fermeture du salon vous maintiennent et
le salaire de votre salarié à 100% où il
travaillait dans un quartier le giro
était parlée dans l'hérault par les
bleus au micro
j'ai fait pas mal aidé par le
gouvernement d'accord faut quand même
solliciter le fait qu enfin ça a été une
grande chance pour moi de pouvoir
solliciter le pge parce que mon chiffre
d'affaires de l'année elle -1 me le
permettez parce que je sais que ce n'est
pas possible dans tout pour toutes les
sociétés et que grâce à ce pge je me
suis permis en tout cas pour soutenir
aussi ma salariés de lui maintenir son
salaire à 100 % ce qui met gars encore
possible aujourd'hui la question que
j'ai à madame la ministre c'est que au
1er confinement allait bien à votre
micro j'ai sollicité le pge que j'ai
obtenu et qui a été calculée sur parce
que j'avais pas obtenu encore mon bilan
2010 neuf donc gilles avait été calculée
sur leur faim il a été oui calculée sur
le bilan 2010 8
auquel cas la banque n'avait pas de
problème en soi puisque
j'avais un chiffre d'affaires que ça
fait 13 ans que je l'installé donc y'a
pas de souci premier confinement
utilisation du pg en partie et je me
demande aujourd'hui si
il faut que je refasse un pg e parce que
si ça dure encore on va dire un mois je
pense qu'on va se retrouver dans une
situation très compliquée pour le
paiement des charges courantes puisqu'on
n'a pas d'exonération pour l'instant
pour les loyers pour le salaire
puisqu'il faut avancer
évidemment les salaires et se faire
rembourser par la suite ça demande du
temps c'est c'est rapide mais ça demande
quand même du temps et je ne suis pas
sûr d'obtenir un deuxième pge puisque il
se trouve que étant dans un quartier
très sensible de paris qui est quartier
de l'opéra qui a été assujettie aux
grands problèmes des gilet jaune des
grèves et aujourd'hui du coc vidalos je
mélange tout mais c'est une pour vous
expliquer la perte de chiffre d'affaires
conséquente depuis quasiment deux ans je
présente un bilan 2010 9 négatifs et je
peux vous dire que ça fait mal au coeur
parce que quand vous savez le travail
qu'on fournisse c'est qu'on me suis
impliqué et aujourd'hui ma banque qui me
soutient je pense mais je sais pas si
dans ce cas là ça marche si je demande
un deuxième pge est ce que j'aurai
l'obtention de ce péché dans le cas où
mon bilan est négatif sur l'année passée
ça voudra dire que j'aurais cumulé quand
même deux crédits avec une perte de
chiffre d'affaires puisqu'on on est
vraiment dans la capacité travail alors
j'ai vraiment cette question qu'il ya
quand même un autre problème que soulève
parce que moi j'estime être chanceuse
parce que je ne vis pas seul à mon foyer
gm enchérit donc il à votre chéri que
vous adorez cher parce que ça je me suis
pas payé quand même ce enfin le mois
concerné nous on n'est pas au chômage en
tant que patron d'accor à rien voilà à
part les 1500 euros dead qui déclenche
et enfin pour l'instant y'a rien qui a
été déclenchée on parle bête mais faut
encore les 1500 nous ont beaucoup aidés
aussi été aussi mais bon c'est pas ça
fait pas tout quoi je dire pour
oui vous professionnel m'a pris je parle
du niveau personnel pour le foyer les
enfants je perds un gérant qui vit seule
avec ses enfants je sais pas de quoi il
vit aujourd'hui ainsi peut pas payer son
loyer et les frais manger ou alors il
est bien dans le micro à la sirec les
coiffeurs ça a été un grand sujet il ya
plein de gens qui ont dit qu'il fallait
les laisser ouverts qui n'ont pas
compris la fermeture des salons de
coiffure
comment vous expliquez que vous ayez
pris la décision de les fermer
et c'est vrai que les salons de coiffure
c'est à part voilà les les grandes
enseignes
ils ont des trésoreries assez serré et
c'est vrai que ne pas pouvoir travailler
novembre décembre déjà ça va être un
très gros coup dur pour eux on le voit
ils ont déjà fait appel un premier jeu
qu'est ce qu'ils font dans le dos dans
le cas de ce monsieur yvon vont faire un
deuxième chiffre d'affaires négatif
voilà c'est ça qui s'il a besoin des
jeux et le lsc qu'il ya déjà à ce jour
3820 dans le micro il ya aujourd'hui à
ce jour négatif 3805 coiffure fermés en
france depuis le déconfinement c'est
pour des gens qui étaient déjà peut-être
dans une situation fragile ce qui
n'était pas je pense le cas de nous tous
coiffeur ici ce soir mais c'est devenu
une situation plus que difficile puisque
in enfin invivable mademoiselle parlé du
fait d'être en couple
moi je suis célibataire je dois faire
face à mes charges seul que j'assumais
jusqu'à aujourd'hui 100 m opposer la
question qui de faire autrement
le problème c'est que les et le peu
d'économies que chacun entend
commerçants je parle attention pas que
de la coiffure mais bon on a tous
consommé le fait qu' il a fallu faire
face aux premières dépenses de 2
d'impôts parce qu on est tous imposable
et il faut payer nos impôts nos loyers
est aujourd'hui mois perçu à titre
personnel je parle j'ai utilisé ma
réserve d'argent et je me retrouve voilà
à vivre sur le pge de la société et je
trouve ça complètement délirant parce
que j'ai pas le choix d'alors juste on
va on va voir alexandre à alexandra
propriétaire d'un salon de coiffure près
de tours au propriétaire de ce salon
depuis onze ans et vous aussi fermeture
du salon au premier confinement et au
deuxième également
7000 euros de manque à gagner sur les
trois mois ferme et deux mois de
trésorerie devant elle
après ça plus de solutions vous avez
déjà fait appel aux aides de l'état
touché en avril mais 1500 euros plus de
1500 euros touché fin mai donc vous quel
est votre question pour la ministre
c'était un peu la question de mes
collègues c'était de savoir enfin
pourquoi on nous a fait fermer nous quoi
bon alors qu'il n'y a aucun danger dans
nos salons j'écoute cole était mis en
place on les a respectés à la lettre
scrupuleusement et voilà nous on veut
travailler nos clients nous demandent
est enfin là et c'est enfin c'est pour
tous les commerces comme ça je dire je
vois pas le risque où il est d'aller
chez le fleuriste et d'être contaminés
chez un fleuriste si le style lui même
fait venir les gens un par an par an
sous forme de rendez vous fin je veux
dire il ya moyen de gérer ces flux en
fait alors voilà madame la ministre est
ce que vous répondez sur les 30 confiant
je vais pas faire le médecin m'assure
main sur le plateau je pense qu il
éclairera le débat sur les aspects de
contamination de réduction des flux etc
maintenant ce que je peux vous répondre
c'est vous me dites tous on a bénéficié
des aides aux premiers confinement les
aides qu'on a mis au premier confinement
en place aujourd'hui celle qu'on fait
sur le seul mois de novembre
sur le seul mois de novembre c'est
l'équivalent de tout le début de l'année
là où vous aviez jusqu'à 1500 euros
c'est jusqu'à 10000 euros dix mille
euros pour couvrir votre chiffre
d'affaires donc vous me dites vous êtes
à peu près dans ces eaux là
en moyenne 9 minuit 1000cc au rythme où
on est on est capable de faire en sorte
que votre chiffre d'affaires il arrive
sur votre compte en banque
début décembre début décembre sur la
base de ce que vous gagnez l'année
dernière ce que vous allez me dire vous
c'est que oui mais alors pas de chance
c'est mon chiffre d'affaires 2010 9
il n'était pas au top mais alors là
aussi on regarde on prend la moyenne de
l'année on sait les calculs qui sont les
plus favorables pour vous soit la
moyenne mensuelle frappant donc sur la
table il ya 15 milliards d'euros 15
milliards d'euros à partir de 10
millions d'euros n'arrive pas très bien
à se représenter les choses en rien
voire même deux cent mille euros mais 15
milliards d'euros
c'est juste gigantesque c'est ce qu'on
met sur la table pour faire en sorte que
les salariés et leurs salaires prise en
charge à 100% ensuite à 84 % pour ceux
qui sont loin payer un peu plus c'est ce
qu'on met sur la table pour mettre dix
mille euros jusqu'à 10000 euros pour des
gens comme vous qui ont leur salon qui
sont fermés et croyez-moi ça nous fait
pas rire ministère de l'économie d'avoir
des gens qui travaillent pas notre job
c'est que les gens travaillent
notre job c'est qu'ils créent de la
richesse c'est qu'ils emploient c'est
que les recrutent
c'est qu'ils forment des apprentis ce
qui est important dans la coiffure c'est
pas très ferme
c'est pas une partie de plaisir dans une
question pour vous être cette ministre
délégué chargé de l'industrie vous vous
auriez conseillez quoi au président de
la république puisque justement vous
votre intérêt c'est que la france
travaille c'est que les commerces
restent ouverts
est-ce que vous avez été vous êtes
ranger du côté du ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand ou es ce que vous avez
dit non nous avec bruno le maire on
aimerait sauver l'économie parce que
forcément il ya eu un moment un vrai
faire je sais que près vous le dites il
me trouve mais il ya eu des échos comme
quoi le président est un petit peu
tiraillé
il a pris sa décision vraiment au
dernier moment mais c'est vrai que vous
vous étiez de quel côté sur le mans
n'était pas du même avis au gouvernement
voilà c'est ça ben en fait exactement ce
qui se passe c'est à dire que vous êtes
autour de la table moi j'ai la casquette
économie vissée sur la tête il dit c'est
pas possible il va falloir quand même
qu'on fait quelque chose sur les
commerçants ils doivent bosser il nous
le demandent et venait enfin solide et
ben tu dis et je vais vous montrer les
chiffres puis ça va calmer tout le monde
montre lui l'étude américaine
mais ouais mais bien sûr qu'on les a
regardés bien sûr vous allez sarsgaard
essayer d'avoir des arguments avec bruno
le maire le minitel économie pas dur à
la fin si vous voulez vous débattez et
on a notre casquette et un moment aussi
non mais attends on a vu la situation
sanitaire et mais on est vu la situation
sanitaire
moi je suis désolé j'ai perdu quelqu'un
dans le coffee ok j'ai perdu le lundi de
pâques
j'en ai un souvenir assez précis donc ce
truc là pour moi il n'est pas
négligeable et vous avez plein de jeunes
qui vont avoir des séquelles
on parle de séquelles neurologiques on
parle de ses cales pulmonaire
ce truc est une saloperie c'est une
saloperie
donc moi j'entends ce que vous dites et
c'est pour ça qu'on met le paquet c'est
pour ça qu'on met le paquet pour que
vous ayez de l'argent il voue pas si le
cap sur le pge alors sur le pge deux
choses la première chose c'est qu'à mon
avis faut commencer par regarder les
aides directes pour pas vous embêter
plus parce qu'effectivement sur la base
de votre bilan 2019
c'est pas nous aurait pas prêt parce que
vous allez le [ __ ] mais c'est
probablement ça sera plus difficile
d'argumenter en revanche d'atomic avec
le mieux c'est de cumuler andrin pge
plus un deuxième pge sept mois ça
faisait ça comme je voulais 10 13 ans
que j'étais installé donc je n'avais
plus de crédit durieux c'est une affaire
qui était je dirais pxl la mécène madame
la ministre est honnête elle vous je
pense qu'elle vous dire que vous n'aurez
pas droit à une deuxième paire jeu avec
un chiffre d'affaires négatif
oui donc c'est vers autre chose qu'il
faut se tourner ces précieux le fertile
en mai et 4 et l'aide de dieu on vous
l'avait dit tout à fait je l'entends et
je sais bien que j'ai droit à une
solution exonérations de cotisations
sociales le fait qu'on prend peut-être
baisse de tva aussi la baisse de la tva
sur d'autres choses peut-être paraître
long mais en fait la tournée de
s'applique sur vos prestations donc si
vous êtes soit infirmée par construction
nous avaient pas terminé je claque pour
la réponse est oui et non puisque nous
ce que nous on sait pour vous donner un
peu le détail et je suis rentré deux
minutes dans la technique et vous me
pardonnerez mais en gros un le pge
on n'est pas obligé de le rembourser ou
mai prochain on peut le prolonger
jusqu'à 6 ans donc ça laisse un petit
peu jusqu'à 60 nouvelles mesures que
vous avez prises non non on pouvait déjà
on pouvait déjà science repose toi bien
sûr et les gens se disent pas bien sur
juine échéant son agression pouvoir la
payer
bah oui non en plus ils peuvent pas ce
que vous remboursez par petites tranches
ils peuvent ne pas en bourse et la
première année c'est à dire on est bien
conscient que l'année 2000 21
enfin l'or quand même que tout le monde
le récupère un peu et de l'oxygène
recommence à faire fonctionner son
commerce
riot on croise les doigts parce que le
coc vide en 2021
il continue de circuler on aurait maxi
un madame un ministre on
on est en train
dessus vous dire j'ai signé des accords
sur ce sujet là on y travaille mais ça
c'est 2021 donc vous commencerez à
rembourser en 2022 et vous pourrez
rembourser jusqu'à 6 ans ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que là vous allez être exonérés de vos
cotisations sociales et vous pouvez
négocier pour ce qui vient derrière avec
les urssaf d'étaler sa sur trois ans les
impôts les impôts quand on est une tpe
on a le droit de demander non loin
d'appeler fisc c'est d'ailleurs le
meilleur moment de ma vie avec le fisc
vous les appelez vous demander une aide
vous les appelez et vouloir demander une
aide
et vous savez quoi on donne des aides
c'est à dire on dit ok cette échéance là
pendant qu'on doit avoir envie de
l'appeler le fisc exactement
et c'est d'ailleurs auprès des services
fiscaux que vous déposez votre demande
pour avoir les 10000 euros
quand même un plaisir hein